Let's look at the solution to our
virtual to physical Translation
speed Quiz.
We were asked,
how many cycles do we need for
our load instruction if we
use 3-level page table?
We need 1 cycle to compute
the virtual address.
We need 10 cycles to access
the outermost page table.
10 cycles to access the next
level of page table,
10 cycles to access
the inner-most page table.
Because neither of those can be cached.
Plus, we need to do the actual
cache access and maybe the memory.
So, overall,
we need 1 + 3 levels of page tables,
times memory latency, plus one
cycle to have a hit in our cache,
plus, 10% of the time, we have.
A miss penalty to access the memory.
This ends up being 33 cycles, 30 of
which are to access the page tables.